what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to a
video um by
brandi lee i am so single the i'm so
lonely the single life it said on the
thumbnail that she was 10 years single
before i start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily
videos how many guys have you dated like
i went through depression come on guys
like do you really hate me that much
going on
why am i still single don't give that
explanation to single people
it doesn't help i was so angry
i'd cry my eyes out i am not broken my
biological clock is not ticking
i just wanted a man this one's the man
to give me forehead kisses
this single life ain't easy but you
can't fix what you can't see
it's the soul that needs a surgery
hey guys and welcome back to my channel
and happy valentine's day
so today's video i'm going to be talking
to you guys about
loneliness and being alone and i kind of
want to take you through my single
journey so far
but i feel like this is the last video
i'm going to make
on my status because i already have two
already
i also feel like god's gonna change my
status real quick
type amen if you agree so i am alone but
i'm not lonely because
i am full but that hasn't always been
the case
so i've been single for 11 years
and i am currently 26 so you guys do the
math
i have dated but i just feel like i
haven't met
the one that feels right you know so
growing up i didn't get much attention
never had a boyfriend never kissed
anyone tiller was like
13 and obviously in school like
is 30 late i think it was 16.
quite late you know girls and boys have
been going out
since they were like seven years old
that was not what
not in my school me at all i never had a
boyfriend
i was the same way i did not date in
high school until i lost my virginity
when i was
which i have talked about in my celibacy
video you can click here to watch
so after that i started dating really
really badly
i loved bad guys i loved guys that had
a name and most of them were just
emotionally
unavailable and this is what they talk
about like the chats like girls go for
the chats and yes i did have major daddy
issues
until i gave my life to christ in 2007
i was really just tired of going around
in circles and just getting messed
around
by the same guys and i do say i gave my
life
but honestly jesus pursued my heart he
chased me down he found me
and he's taking me on this journey of
wholeness and i must say
it has not been an easy ride at all so i
was
introduced to heather lindsey very early
on
in my journey okay so this is
because i saw another thing that said my
journey to celibacy and this is what
kevin samuels
talks about when he says you're making
men of the future pay for mistakes of
your past
she really introduced me to like
intentional dating
not dating randoms and just being
content in your singleness so
a lot of my standards and my convictions
come from obviously god and the bible
but a lot of them come from just like
listening to
heather lindsey if you guys don't know
who heaven lindsey is i'll put a picture
here
and i'll put a link below honestly
there's been times when i've been in
like
wrong relationships or situation ships
and i'll go on instagram and she's
written a post that just basically
convicts my heart and i'm just like
damn like i hate it but i love it at the
same time because i know god is always
trying to protect me and he uses other
people to speak to me
so i'm really grateful for heaven
lindsay's voice in the world because i
don't know
if i would have got as far if it wasn't
for heaven lindsay i'm just going to be
real so i know a lot of you guys hear me
tell stories about this x and this guy
that i was dating and this guy and this
guy
and i know some of you are probably
thinking like damn britney how many guys
have you dated and honestly
i like to extract as much experience
from
these situations as possible it's only
been like four or five like if i can be
real it's only been like four or five
different guys in the whole 10 11 years
that i've been dating it seems like
every other year the devil sends me numb
jake now i'm joking i feel like somehow
i just start
talking to guys and before you know it
i've already caught feelings because i
catch feelings so fast like god this
is probably looking at me like another
one like seriously
no but seriously i just feel like if god
doesn't say go
then it's a no like this that's just how
i do relationships okay
if god doesn't say go it's a no like
tweet that
okay here's sometimes i think women's
standards are too high
and then they end up alone i don't know
her personally it just seems like
you know you didn't have these
requirements for the last
guy but now the next guy you're going to
have all these requirements for
i'm not sure that strategy is going to
work but let me
but throughout the year there's
definitely been times when i've just
been like super single nobody's checking
for rini like
nobody's making my hot line bling it's
just
dead and then the next thing you know mr
right now is knocking on my door and i'm
just like
i'm weak okay
so be like fully single for a year and
then i'm talking to someone
then god says no then i break it up and
i'm single for a year
and then talking to someone and then god
says no then i break it up
and the cycle goes on again i'm really
making light of the situation oh so she
breaks it up it's not that i don't know
what that's
legit how it happens god's just like
no no no no no no so majority of the
relationship that i've been in
it's just like i didn't have peace about
them and you know you're in a wrong
relationships when you can't even pray
about it you don't want to pray about it
because you don't want god to say
no what's going to say
not that one no he's not the one sorry
next but i like to believe that god has
big plans for us
and okay i disagree with this piece of
dating advice from the church and i i
consider myself a christian
i believe in god i believe in the church
but i think that dating is a lot more
the choices that we make versus
god just having that one person waiting
for you
you have to deserve and earn a husband
he doesn't just send you someone that's
perfect for you have to deserve him you
have to earn him
um and especially in the church i think
one piece of dating advice that doesn't
pan out for a lot of people
is you got to date within your church
um i understand why they would say that
um but the problem is most churches it's
like one guy to three girls
so if that's the case then three
out of four are gonna or two out of the
three are going to end up alone
oh so just my two cents big plans for me
and he'll never tell me to let go of
something without a reason he may not
tell me the reason
but there is a reason you know but
obviously it's difficult when you've
like caught feelings and stuff and you
have to tell them
my daddy don't like you and he likes
everyone
like you know when you have to just like
break it to them but
it'd be like that sometimes you know but
let me just be honest a part of me did
really just
enjoy casually dating dating for no
reason
talking to someone it made me feel happy
when i was talking to someone
yeah girls we like validation yeah going
out on
dates just doing cute [ __ ] thought of
having a bae to me it was just like
happiness it was just bliss even though
at the back of my mind i was like i know
this is not going to work
but i thought whilst i'm waiting for the
one i might as well have some fun
hey that rhymes since i'm single aka
wasting their time and attention oh i
might as well have some fun and i mean
good fun i mean i wasn't out here
sleeping with guys you know but
i was just like let me just go on dates
like let me just get a little
feel you know let me just do me you know
i'm not doing that anymore and this is
why a lot of guys are frustrated with
dating because girls will look at them
as
fun and they're celibate so they're not
sleeping with them
well because it's so stressful it's so
much work and that's why i don't really
date anymore like i don't date
like i don't go on random days i don't
just
i don't do it anymore no god says no i
will pay straight away
other times i'm just like tiptoeing i'm
just taking my time and everything
and then i'm just like no god let me
have this one
having said all of that 2015 to 2017
was like my hardest years ever
like i went through depression before i
turned 25 in 2016
and i was struggling with like deep deep
deep loneliness and i would say that
it's because
i didn't have a man but i think it was a
lot deeper than that i really feel like
the first six years
of like being single was a lot more
easier because i felt like i had a
really good group of friends around me
and there was always something to do
you'd be hanging out like
it was fun man it was fun being single
back then my friends
really held me down but in 2016 2017
a lot of my friendship started to
crumble and through that rejection i
just started to like isolate myself
i became really cold and really hard
and i kept myself to myself i just
became really guarded
on top of that i felt like like everyone
in my family were dying
like literally in a space of like two to
three years i lost
like two aunties two uncles and my
grandad passed away
and my family are super super close and
as long as i've been born i hadn't been
to a food hall i hadn't been to a family
food anymore like no one in my family
had died
so you can imagine that pressure on me
like as a like what 24 25
year old i was just like finding it
really hard to cope
and because of my personality i
internalized pain
so i just kept everything inside i kept
everything buried and i probably like
cried
only once or twice out of all of those
years that my family members were
passing away like
i became so numb i became so numb and so
cold
and like my family were on the edge my
mum was suffering from anxiety
i had to really like help her and
console her like at least once a week
i had just graduated university i was
trying to build my online platform
trying to find my feet in this new big
wide world i was just simply
overwhelmed and at the time i started
seeing a counselor
um who i'm still seeing to this day she
has been amazing she's been a big help
like i really started to rebuild my life
i felt like my life had purpose and i
thought yes i can actually do this but
last year
loneliness creeped back up on me and i
felt this time it was justified
like both my sisters were in
relationships one was actually engaged
even my brother was in a relationship my
friends even my 15 year old niece had a
boyfriend
has a boyfriend and like i'm just here
trying to be successful
flourishing making videos doing my whole
soul surgery thing
but i felt so alone and like before
those kind of things wouldn't even like
bother me it wouldn't even phase me
but i felt like everything was just
casting a shadow
on how lonely i was like everything just
kept reminding me
of how lonely physically you know at
least she's being honest
because a lot of girls would be will say
oh i'm so happy single
it's great single life even encouraged
their friends to be single but
at the end of the day most women crave
intimacy and companionship
and inside i was and i really started to
feel really embarrassed
like that is like no joke i actually
started to feel really
really embarrassed and i was just like
come on guys like do you really hate me
that much that you would keep me single
for this long
and on top of that this is that's the
problem with that thinking
it's it's not god it's you
you are in control of your destiny you
are in control of who you marry
it's not god and i believe in god i'm a
christian i just
i think we are more in control of our
lives than he made me feel this anguish
in my soul like i've never i heard
people being upset about being single
before
i wasn't just single i was alone there's
actually a difference between being
single
and alone i was feeling so
lonely i was at my lowest point and i
started to look around at people who
were like in
intentional godly relationships and i
started to think like i mean they
haven't been single as long as i have
and i know for sure they haven't done
the work on themselves so what's going
on why am i still single it's like
you'll hear sermons and preachers say
oh god has you single because he's
working on you
and that was great for the first six
years but then i'm just like
come on god am i that broken that you're
taking so long to mend me and fix me
don't give that explanation to single
people it doesn't help
it does not help and of course it has
elements of truth to it of course in
those years i've been single i've had
time to work on myself
and i won't take that about for anything
but that's not the reason somebody is
single
because there's people out here who've
never really been single
at all and they're married and they're
in relationships what work have they
done on themselves
so it's not fair to say you're single
because a
you're not ready or two god is working
on you
house way how no i agree with her
like it's not that it's there's
something holding you back and typically
most girls don't know what it is
they're either batting out of their
leaks so it's like a girl that's a five
is going for a seven
and she can't get a seven right um
it's it might be their weight it might
be that they're not feminine
for her like i would tell her to take
out the
that whatever that is maybe like do a
little less makeup because
that when guys see heavy makeup and they
see piercings they put you
in the category of girl like to sleep
with and not wife
um so i really recommend girls go a
little bit more natural
how what else i gotta do like what else
what else he's working on me yeah okay
but how long are you going to be working
on me god
and i know that may sound really
arrogant but it's reality that's how i
was feeling
that's how i felt at the time i'd really
talk to god and just give it to god and
just be like
god are you serious like are you serious
am i that messed up like
how much more work do you want to do on
me and i'll start going into my pity
party talking about
how i've always felt lonely since i was
a child
i'll start going back into childhood
stuff i'd cry my eyes out
until i had a headache and i'd hear god
whisper
am i not enough and i would whisper back
no i need a real man i need a physical
man
need a man of real arms to give me like
real
hugs not spiritual hugs real physical
hugs one of my love language is
physical touch put in the work girl go
on
and this is this is the thing
we're not told that we need to put into
the work to find someone we're always
told they'll find us and that's just not
always
a man to help me support my dreams not
too much to arts
god god like i really do love you i
really do
i need to be held with real arms i need
to be heard with
real ears i needed to be touched with
real hands
they keep telling me god that you are
enough for me but why do i still feel so
empty these are some of the questions i
had for god and i had to keep it real
and obviously saying these things to you
you may be like you can't talk to god
like that
yes i can that's my relationship with
him you got to be real man this single
life ain't easy
i even remember telling god like if i'm
not in a relationship in a year then i'm
gonna wild out
i was vex i was so angry
and lo and behold i entered into a
situation with someone that was
seriously toxic
because ultimately we was only supposed
to be friends we should have never
crossed the line but to be honest i was
lonely he was lonely
i was using him to fill my voids and he
was using me to fill
his void and it was just a recipe for
disaster but i seriously thank god for
that moment in time because it really
has brought me to this place where i am
right now
like it really caused a shift in
consciousness like i am
so full i lack nothing
i am not a half waiting for my other
half to appear
i am already whole and i am enough
but back then i really really believed
that i needed a man to make me happy i
was not happy i really thought the
reason for my unhappiness
was because i didn't have a man i felt
like i'd be completed
once i was found i think that's how a
lot of women feel
and the problem with society is that we
tell women oh
that shouldn't be the case that's not a
real feeling you need to find yourself
be happy with yourself
and if you're not happy being alone
i think it'd be a little bit more
effective to say okay these are the
tools you need to go find a husband this
is what you have to do
it's actually a big lie a man can only
add to your happiness he can't make you
happy
that is an inside job take it from
someone who actually deeply believed
that she needed the man can you imagine
a whole me
it's not true it is not
true honestly self-love is your greatest
asset
i don't expect a man to replace the love
that i have for myself
i'm setting myself up for failure and
i'm really setting myself up for
codependency
like if someone loves me i'm going to be
great
if someone doesn't love me i'm also
going to be great
not statistically
uh women over 45 that don't
that aren't married don't have higher
levels of happiness
and see this this is a lie that society
says they tell
women that you'll be fine if you end up
alone
but women aren't built for that i mean i
would say a select few
are but it's not the majority and
instead of saying oh just be happy alone
maybe say these are the tools you need
to get there
because i already love my
self i am full a man's love should
compliment you
not make you honestly us females get it
wrong all
of the time a lot of guys do too don't
get it twisted that's why
unhealthy relationships are on an
all-time rise like one person is
depending on the other person for life
and i always equate it to like when you
go deep to dive in
and each person has an oxygen tank and
that's needed in order
to survive to to breathe but i like in
some
toxic relationships to two people go
deep-sea diving
and only one has an oxygen tank and what
happens then is that the other person is
replying on the other person's tank
for oxygen
while the other person suffers how much
more fun would relationships be
if both people came into the
relationship with their own
tank and they wasn't relying on the
other person to give them
life because they had their own this is
the way that i see self-love
if you give yourself the love that you
want
i see something you give your the
problem is she she doesn't define that
this is what i see self-love as getting
therapy if you need therapy if you've
been in toxic relationships and had
negative stuff have happened to you go
get
therapy if you're overweight go to the
gym
looking nice in the morning like that
those are all
indicators of self-love so she doesn't
really quantify yourself the attention
you so desperately desire from other
people
you will be full repeat after me
i am responsible
for my own happiness i
am responsible for my own
happiness how good did that feel that
alone literally brings about so much
contentment in my life i'm
absolutely not where i want to be in
life but i am focused
i am focused on becoming better not to
get a man
but to get me to love me to cherish me
to honor me to respect
me i'm also in a good place spiritually
like i know how to love myself because i
know how much god
loves me and he teaches me to love
myself by showing me
how he sees me i'm not broken i am not
unlovable
i am not hard to love my biological
clock is not ticking my biological clock
is perfect
it literally is i hate all girls
you literally only have so much time to
have kids don't rush into a relationship
don't marry someone you shouldn't
because
you're anxious you're running out of
time i don't think like kevin samuels
will say stuff like
if you're an 8 over 2 under the age of
25 mary the first
the um the guy
pursuing you there that's trying to
marry you
and i don't necessarily agree with that
because i don't i don't think we should
rush into things
but you should date intentionally
there are still good men out here all
men do not cheat
i will have a successful marriage being
single is
not a curse a husband is not a reward
and i am the prize like we really have
to
break i am the prize
i don't see it like that i don't think
women
women are a prize if you put in the work
to be one
but
you need to work to get a husband and i
do think that a husband is a reward for
putting in the work
some girls naturally they're just very
pretty they don't have to do anything
some girls are naturally very feminine
they don't have to do anything and some
girls
have to work it just is what it is down
these mental barriers
if we truly want to be whole like we
really need to break down these
mental barriers and these lies that we
tell ourselves i always see it like this
love god love yourself and love others
that is the ten commandments in a
nutshell love for god
love for self and love for others and
until you become comfortable being alone
you'll never know if you're choosing
someone out of love
or pure loneliness when we choose
people from a place of scarcity we
create more scarcity i do
i do agree with that i do 100 agree
but when we choose people from a place
of wholeness we create
more wholeness and trust me when i say
this someone has learned the lesson
the relationship that you have of
yourself is the most important
relationship
on this earth from there you are able to
love
somebody else it all starts right here
with you but some of you don't believe
that and seriously the reason why some
of you don't believe that is because we
don't love ourselves
and we don't love ourselves because we
don't like ourselves and we don't like
ourselves because we judge ourselves
and we judge ourselves because we don't
know
ourselves i promise you if you get to
know you
you'll realize that you're not as bad as
you think you are you're not as bad as
you tell yourself of course you you're
not perfect
of course you make mistakes i thought i
was probably the most screwed up person
there is
i thought i'd never be free but i sit
here
as a testament that with god all things
are possible
i have never been so happy so content
with my lot nothing has changed
physically i'm still
single but something has shifted in my
consciousness
in my mind like i've become new
because i've realized that i can't rely
on anybody
to give me what i need to give myself i
can't expect guys i'm looking up for
instagram to see this was
two years ago so i just kind of want to
see
if she
ended up finding someone
does not look like it i don't see
anything
i wanted to go to her tagged pictures
um no
yeah so the problem is that the advice
that she's been given clearly doesn't
yield results and that's the problem
with the church
is i love i love church i literally love
church
but they don't give great dating advice
expect love from someone else and negate
to give myself that love that i'm
seeking in other people
you are love there's enough love in you
to give to yourself and also to give to
somebody else
but the foundation of every relationship
should be self-love
okay um
i thought that this was an interesting
video
i don't know i think some of the advice
that was my feeling was that some of the
advice that she'd been given was a
little bit misguided especially in the
church
god sorry goodness um the church gives
such bad dating advice oh my gosh such
bad dating
advice oh my gosh um but let me know in
the comments what you guys think
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
ring the notification bell and i will
talk to you guys
next